hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
the show that goes there stacy
hey well we have been tracking
inflation right for the past few months
it's looking worse and worse and worse
well we have on our hands
feeding the racket starving the racket
feeding the racket is the central banks
feeding
the grift right of this whole global
ponzi scheme fiat ponzi scheme that's
been going on for 50 years
now since 1971 and a bitcoin
is starving the racket we're going to
start off with this story out of korea
this is nexon which is a 30 billion
gaming company
and nick carter tweets a link to their
statement on why they bought 1717
bitcoin
m1 posting isn't just for coiners and
gold bugs 30 billion
korean conglomerate do it too and with
government spending and debt levels so
high even a small rise in interest rates
would make paying down the debt even
more difficult than it already is so
central banks have been increasingly
monetizing the debt printing money to
loan to the government in the form of
buying government bonds
at low interest rates since january 2020
the us has printed 40
more u.s dollars than previously existed
we are not privy to conversations at
central banks or departments of
treasuries
but we foresee no end to this in the
near term
and then they go on to say well we can't
predict what interest rates will do
we can see that the inflation is going
to eat away our treasury
right that's 100 million dollars that
they bought in bitcoin and you know this
is the echo of the 1971
day when gold window was closed by
richard nixon we went under all fiat
standard and within a few decades as
nomi prince writes about in her book
collusion
all global central banks were colluding
on this money printing scheme
that would devalue everyone's currency
their purchasing power
and then starting with michael sayler at
microstrategy
here in the united states his company
and now there are almost 40 companies
and now companies in asia are launching
what you would call speculative attack
they're calling the central planners and
the central
bankers bluff they're saying ha ha
we see you you're printing trillions
and we're going to buy bitcoin with that
and we're going to defund
you uh similar to what soros did in 1993
to the bank of england but this is done
now on a
global scale a multi-hundred trillion
dollar scale
and that's why bitcoin price is going to
500 600 700 000.
well many have said that we're in a
similar situation to the great
depression and the great depression of
course also saw
geopolitical game theory happening and
beggar thy neighbor
i think it was the uk who actually
pulled themselves off the gold standard
first
then or revalued gold in order to
diminish their own debts and
try to fight the deflation so you're
seeing the same thing on the other side
here
as rapid money printing just accelerates
and
in an all fiat world it's difficult to
protect yourself as a
as a company with hundreds of millions
sometimes billions of dollars on your
balance sheet so how do you protect
yourself um we saw
with tesla's earnings report just in the
past
week we saw that obviously they made a
lot of money it was a good
decision that they made to uh convert
some of their you know it was like
1.7 billion dollars worth of their
balance sheet that they converted to
bitcoin and that has helped keep their
earnings up
but an interesting thing so he uh so
nexon and korea mentions that they
they're not privy to how central banks
and treasuries plan on
what they're doing with this money
printing and whether or not it'll ever
end they predict it won't end but there
was a member of parliament in canada who
released a video
of him questioning the central bank head
of
you know the central bank of canada and
um he
notes that the trudeau government is
borrowing three billion dollars a week
you'll never guess how much the central
bank is printing for a week
so he asked the central banker how much
quantitative easing they were currently
engaged in
and the guy admitted to three billion a
week
and this canadian member of parliament
was like
how convenient because we're also
borrowing 3 billion a week
right so again this is confirming on a
global basis
from different governments and different
politicians are waking up
to the fact that the central banks
are printing with the stated goal of
helping the unemployed
and to stimulate the economy and
as politicians and corporate ceos are
pointing out
that stated goal is increasing
unemployment
and increasing the loss of purchasing
power and
increasing the plight of poor the poor
it does help those who are asset holders
uh they are becoming fabulously rich so
the split between rich and poor
is growing spectacularly and in that
video it's amazing because
the politician points out the obvious
failure uh by the central bank of canada
to make any
sense he says that uh they have a two
percent
inflation target in the video and the
politician says you've already blown
past two percent
and you're causing real painful
inflation everywhere
and the central banker simply keeps
repeating like a monkey on drugs
you know the same talking points right
they they have no cognitive ability to
understand they're programmed to do this
they they might as well just have a
rhesus monkey with a
i think a reese's monkey would do better
than these uh
these these bots these keynesian bots
well certainly
as you mentioned the asset prices are
indeed going up
creating the cantillionaire class in
canada is quite extraordinary
we've reported that u.s house prices
have been up 16
in the past year thanks to all the money
printing in canada
it's up 32 percent so
the average price increase in some
provinces or a hundred thousand
over the year the median price so you
are
choosing a a group of winners that are
in the lucky
house club you know they get they happen
to be old enough when
prices were not this high before all the
money printing began
and so they own the assets and they you
know it consolidates their
um the wealth and income gap the wealth
gap
most importantly in this article that
edward harrison for example links to the
housing boom is ripping apart the
financial fabric of canadian life
young adults increasingly feel shut out
of home ownership in big cities
even as their parents can't stop talking
about how much money they've made as
owners
so you have that intergenerational gap
that we've warned about
for over 10 years now here on kaiser
report but
the problem especially is that there are
some
really big winners like anybody the
boomers who owned property in toronto
or outside vancouver or any of these big
cities they're able to extract
they take the helocs you know the home
equity loan
out of their property take some equity
out and give it to their children to get
on this property ladder that's
going up by 30 a year so you're gifting
them
a hundred thousand a year income in uh
money printing
it's nepotism plus despotism
is what we've got going on around the
world and all these different it's so
obvious now to everybody including the
rank and file politician that the money
printing
causes the poverty increases the wealth
and income gap
and in increases the unemployment and
the social
misery that comes with it so what we've
been saying now for
at least five years you know pointing
out we've had bankers and
academics and students and we've been
talking about this for five years and
five years ago was considered to be
uh a theory or a heterodox theory
and now it's become uh an accepted
wisdom
fact you know that's what investigative
journalists do you don't even need to be
an investigative journalism
journalist to find this out we're going
to look at this tweet
from ben askren who is an mma fighter
so a boxer has had his head punched in a
few times and
uh even he even though he's been punched
around quite a few times in his life
he tweets curious if this will be
reflected in the cpi
they want you to think that inflation
doesn't exist rolling eyes rolling eyes
rolling eyes emoji
bitcoin and that is would cost to build
a deck so they look at the average
lumber prices
using 2 400 board feet which is 200
square feet
april 2020 cost you 936 dollars to build
a deck
now it costs you 3696
which is uh what i guess that's fourfold
if i could do some math here
right well here's the thing over the
last 20 years china has
was operating as a wage sink right all
the wages
and those jobs went to china and their
cost of labor was
one fraction of what it was in north
america
but now that that's caught up you've got
wage parity between china and the u.s so
you don't have that
wage sink anymore so now the cost for
stuff
the average person down there at the box
store
is that and energy and food is up
sharply and
bored to build uh houses uh it is simply
now going to
spill over the dike that's been put in
place to try to hide the fact that
we're doing a policy of money printing
to help our friends
on park avenue that has gone on for 20
years
while they outsource the job to china
now we've got wage parity so that
wage sink that was a the ability to
understate inflation for years is done
and now the numbers that are going to
come in are going to show real
quarter to quarter cpi runaway
inflation and all the policymakers are
going to
a run you won't find them
the phone will be dead they're simply
going to run away
b they're going to blame some magical
existential threat that they'll pull out
of their hollywood hat
and do little films about but we know
that this was completely
and entirely avoidable as we've been
saying for five years
now you know that there's always those
economists or ceos or business people
that once they retire then they admit
like oh my god it's all a fraud they
never do it while they're collecting
their huge salaries the people in the
health insurance racket
so here we have and you and i have been
questioning whether you know this is the
50th birthday of an all fiat world we'll
be
in august of uh 2021. we went off the
gold center
in august of 1971. so this feels like
what we're seeing from the stimulus
programs
with huge amounts of fiscal stimulus
over the past year this is extraordinary
over the past 20 years
we've had massive amounts of central
bank loose
policies giving credit to the elite of
wall street
but now it's like it seems like as it's
crumbling globally and deglobalization
is setting and then you get
biden set to unveil a 1.8 trillion
expansion
of american social safety net so there
seems to be
you know okay it's all over hey in the
last few moments of this
ponzi scheme we'll give you some of
these crumbs so
i mean there are some good policies like
they're you know they're giving a lot
for child care
but on the other hand it's like spewing
money for
university students which will support
the
obviously racket of the whole education
system here which is overpriced and all
these administrators so
basically they're like very highly paid
uh government sector workers at these
universities
it's the old times square three card
monty trick yeah
okay after the three-card monty guy rips
the tourists off for all the money they
have
they let them win the last twenty dollar
hand
before they go away big losers and in
the mind of the punter
he's like aha i won so here's joe biden
he's
clinton biden neoliberalism
ravaging trillions from the middle class
creating a huge number of the newly poor
and on their way out
they're saying here catch this nickel
between your teeth
and you can keep it thanks joe swell guy
very swell indeed oh yeah he swelled
he's swollen for sure hey
we can't swell or inflate this segment
we got to take a break when we come back
more on this show don't go away
back to the kaiser report i'm max keiser
time now to turn to
james turk of goldmoney.com full
disclosure i am an investor
james turk welcome back thanks max it's
always great to be with you
all right we're gonna pick your brain on
some big issues here stock prices are at
all-time highs
property prices are rocketing by
double-digit percentage points
commodities are on a chair why are we
getting so much monetary and fiscal
stimulus
if it looks like we are in boom times i
don't get it
explain too much money printing by
central banks around the world
uh they're debasing currencies and as a
consequence what you're seeing is the
early stages of a flight out of the
currency into real things
so the policymakers tell us something
different right they
they what are the what do they tell us
exactly how do they how do they get away
with this
they tell us what they want us to hear
they don't necessarily tell us the whole
story
and all of this money printing that's
going on means that there's a lot of
inflation in the plan and we're
starting to see that you know lumber
prices food prices
uh everything pretty much across the
board you know people are looking for
alternatives to national currencies
and that's why the stock market's going
up as well max
that it's better to own stocks than to
own something dollar denominated
because at least at the end of the year
you odds are that the stock
will have tangible assets the value of
which will go up in the
debased dollars where if you put dollars
in deposit in a bank you don't earn
enough
interest income to offset the loss of
purchasing power because of inflation
so put your money into things other than
dollar denominated assets
now here are the words weimar germany
now almost every day i see somebody
talking about it
michael bury who uh of course wrote the
big
short uh or he participated in the big
short on wall street they made a movie
about it
uh he was writing about this comparing
the current situation to weimar germany
and then he kind of disappeared from
twitter the nine years of boom time
inflation
that ended in hyperinflation is what
happened there
and all the time in weimar germany the
central bank was saying that
the money the inflation was transitory
that the money printing had nothing to
do with these stock prices
uh skyrocketing to new highs is the
comparison to weimar germany which is a
pretty
pretty dramatic comparison is it
warranted though james i think it is
warranted max and you know i think we're
on the same path
because what's happening is weimar
germany was spending money
the government was spending money they
were returning to the central
bank um the reichsbank in order to print
the currency
uh and that's what they did and that's
the same thing that's happening now in
the united states but there's a
fundamental difference
the economy in weimar germany was a cash
currency economy
in other words at the end of the month
companies used to pay their employees
with a pay packet
with reichsmark banknotes stuffed in it
nobody had a checking account back then
the deposit currency
money on deposit in the banking system
was
mainly in businesses and not individuals
in the united states today we have a
very different type of
currency system most transactions are
done with deposit currencies a very
sophisticated banking system
so you're not going to see piles of
notes like
occurred in weimar germany or zimbabwe
you're going to see an inflation like
occurred in argentina
or brazil where they had very
sophisticated backing banking systems
and everyone
had bank accounts instead of printing
paper the central bank
does bookkeeping and adds zeroes to the
government's checking account
uh which the government then spends so
it's it's hyperinflation
we're on the road to hyperinflation it's
a question of whether they get off of it
before the currency is destroyed
or whether we go over the cliff so the
federal reserve and the government says
that they've got a two percent
target on inflation uh but they also
admit now that we've broke through two
percent we're
they're heading to three percent shadow
stats which of course tracks the real
inflation
if you were to unwind all the hedonic
adjustments and statistical mirages that
are put in there to hide it
tells us that inflation is really over
10 percent 12 percent now in fact
and um we see commodities as you point
out lumber
doubling and tripling in price copper
new all-time high
agriculture new all highs and yet
the language that comes out of the
central planners is they say
quote we are fighting deflation
how do they how does that how do they
even misuse that word to that degree
james so listen to what they say watch
what they're doing
i think that's the key um you know they
talk about
things being transitory well the 1970s
were translatory but you had inflation
for 10
or over actually 15 years that was
decimating
um and it's the same thing that's
happening now but we're just at the
beginning of this max that's the scary
thing
and the federal reserve yesterday said
they're going to continue printing
110 billion dollars a month of
new currencies being created every month
by the federal reserve so looking at
some of these
corporations what's going on on the
corporate level micro
trip shortages are hitting production of
all sorts of goods from automobiles to
smartphones
i saw that ford just reported numbers
for the quarter they said they're going
to reduce
capacity by 50 because of a smart chip
um you know uh reduction we're seeing
shipping shortages develop as stimulus
checks to american
pour into china for manufactured goods
from china
will we see widespread supply shortages
in 2021.
so uh an ancillary
impact of this money printing seems to
be
supply shortages uh this is is that
going to also develop or we're going to
see start rationing of goods and things
like that james
well let's hope they don't ration in
goods because uh
price fixing and rationing and that is a
step backwards and it's going to kill
the economy even worse than
uh debasing the currency the shortages
come from the problem that
you need a sound money in order to
perform economic calculation properly
so when a company plans for something
they need to have a sound
monetary unit in order to do their
investment planning
you can't do that easily in an
inflationary economy
uh and you know the way to
to to do that is to hire an accountant
who lived through the argentinian
hyperinflation
who understands how um the problems that
arise when you're
actually in an inflationary environment
another element of the course max is
that
a lot of people would rather hoard
things or hold things rather than sell
them for the prices because they know
that
to replicate them at a future date it's
going to cost a lot more
so in an inflationary economy you do see
a lot of shortages occurring
it's not that the stuff doesn't exist
it's just that people would rather hold
on to it
because at least they have something of
value rather than a depreciating
currency
right you mentioned sound money and of
course we've been talking now for
over 15 years we've been having james
turk on talking to james turk and
i was talking about sound money and gold
of course has been sound money for a
long long time
and it just seems that what a lot of
people miss is that
when you are navigating the territory of
the economy you need to have at least
one
fixed point you know if you're sailing
on the ocean you need a north star
when you're building a house you need a
12-inch
foot standard measurement to use to
build your house here in this economy in
the global economy since 1971
there since it's not gold back we have
essentially an ideology
based currency and then an
ideology-based
definition of what constitutes gdp
right it's ideology and ideology out and
it's become
ludicrously random it's just when i hear
jay powell and these
people talk now it's like word salads
coming out of their mouth
grounded in it's like an e e cummings
poem or something
it makes no frickin sense james no
you're exactly right
and you know it's very it's a very keen
point
uh that you're bringing up about having
a unit um
in money the unit is called a numer for
example during the british empire the
numerator
was the british sovereign gold coin
which weighed point
two four three five ounces of gold it
doesn't say at a british sovereign that
it's one pound
uh because everybody knew that a british
sovereign was one pound
as the same thing originally with the
framers of the constitution when they
created uh
in the mint act of 1792
the eagle and the double eagle uh
everybody knew what an eagle was and
everybody knew what a double eagle was
um it was it was the numerator we don't
have a numerator anymore max
and that's the problem that applies i
mean not to be
uh some people would equate this with a
certain
conservativism and thought because they
like to go on these wild tangents about
how we could all live on a beautiful
island of paradise
called shangri-la where all people are
self-actuating in real time and
but that the result now
is that nobody's getting civil rights
nobody's getting human rights
nobody's participating in
representational government anymore
it's completely incomplete malevolent
anarchy
in the uk in the u.s and around the
world
there's a total societal breakdown james
for this very reason
am i exaggerating no you're not
exaggerating because
when the currency is no good the only
way you can force that currency into
circulation
is through laws penalties and
enforcement
um and regimentation and that's what
we're seeing we're losing our freedoms
we're losing our liberties
in order to make this bad currency
circulate you know
again we're going further and further
down this road we're going to end up
like venezuela
if we don't get off this road so you hit
the nail on the head there
uh because the money's so bad the only
way to get people to use it
is through is through coercion and
effectively
state violence and that's what we're
seeing in the united states now is more
and more incursion by the state and
with a very violent extremist autocratic
edge to accept the problem is
they're trying to get people to accept
complete garbage
as a numeraire as a unit of account as
something worth working for
and uh predictably the results are
becoming
untenable if not downright
insurrectionist
now let's talk about the broader economy
a little bit
uh at the end of the first quarter the
bank of america argued that the 40-year
bond bull market was over and it's even
possible
when the central bank is so they said
the bond bull market's over
you know people have been saying this
for at least 15 years
you know that it's been the widow maker
people say oh the bond market's finished
but at some point if in fact this
currency is
as garbage as as we're saying the bond
market will in fact
the bull market will in fact end uh and
and that would
that would be the end of uh a lot of uh
assumptions in terms of how the economy
works but
are you willing to delve into the deep
end and make a a call here about the
pond market james
i think the bull market in the bond
in bonds has already ended the only
reason why it's continued to go on
longer than would normally be the case
is we don't have a free market
anymore uh you know financial repression
is the policy of central banks around
the world
and they're buying all of these bonds um
to keep interest rates low um and
i if it wasn't for central bank buying
all of these bonds
interest rates and bonds would be much
much higher we saw a little blip
up last year you know the bond
vigilantes of the 1970s
um some people said are quiet
now well the reason why they're quiet is
because they're being overrun by central
banks
so i think you know getting back to what
we were talking about on currency and
avoiding things that are dollar
denominated avoid dollar denominated
bonds
avoid dollar denominated bank deposits
avoid anything dollar denominated
own tangibles or near tangibles like
stocks of companies that own tangibles i
think that's the only safe answer going
forward from here
until we turn around and get off this
road toward hyperinflation
all right james turk we're going to have
to have a second segment this is just
too good
thanks for being on kaiser report thanks
max all right that's gonna do it for
this edition of kaiser report with me
max keiser and stacey herbert want to
thank our guest james turk of
goldmoney.com until next time bye y'all
you